man I love comic-con I really do yeah I  really do love comic-con ilysm it's the  only place in the world where the phrase  I'm wearing a wristband will get you  laid and I love that oh no it's really  funny it's you know I love I love and I  love this every year it's fun to see  regular everyday people cosplaying as  superheroes I think that's really nice  yeah finally an answer to the question  what would Batman look like if he only  ate at Buffalo Wild Wings  [Applause]  [Laughter]  I'll get you Joker I'm learning a lot  and my knowledge about how things  comic-con is increasing this week I've  learned that Thor comes from Asgard  Black Panther from Wakanda and the wasp  is from Connecticut Greenwich there's a  new did you hear this there's a new push  in superhero movies to create  superheroes who look like real nerds  instead of Jason Momoa or Chris Evans  yeah yeah the people behind this idea  are described as not women  [Applause]